There are any tests at the ensuing radiation of the chemo.
Is there any danger for me to be around others?
We have a brand new grandchild and very elderly parents.
This is a good question.
I don't think anybody's asked this question before.
Now, if you ask your ecologist this question,
they probably say, no, absolutely not.
You're fine.
But the truth is, is if you're doing radiation,
is there a radioactivity that could shed?
If you're doing chemo IVs, is there chemotherapy?
Is that something that could, that drug could that be shedding?
Now, again, if you ask anybody in the medical field,
they'd say, no, that's nonsense.
But we're smarter than that.
The truth is, yes, that probably could take place.
Now, the shedding of a chemical from chemo,
probably have some sort of half-life.
And chemo really does its work within 48 hours,
and it dissipates fairly quickly after that,
especially if you're working on trying to detox it.
If you're exchanging bodily fluids,
that's going to be even worse.
So I'd be careful on how, if you have a new grandchild,
I'd be careful how close you get to the new grandchild
or the elderly parent and making sure
that you're not exchanging any bodily fluids
like kissing and having saliva exchange.
Yeah, there's risk in that.
We saw that with this last vaccine with the mRNA shedding.
That's a real thing.
And don't anybody tell you that it's not
because that can happen.
So I would be careful, yes, I would be careful.
I can't, I don't know, you can look at the studies.
I know there are some studies on shedding
with the mRNA vaccine that you could dig up.
But I don't think, I don't know what, if there's any studies,
there may be some studies on radiation.
I don't think there's any studies on chemo.
I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.